Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two David Pakman.
You can call any time. I am slowly going through
the 600 voicemails I have from when I was away.
Here is one that came in about a guy whose friends
are going to fake vaccine cards. Take a listen.
Speaker 2: Hi, David. Big fan of your show. I
just found out very heartbreaking that two of my
friends that I was close with and they both plan
on getting fake covid vaccine card. And I tried to
report them to the local Department of Health. I'm
not sure if I'm doing enough, though, if I can get
any insight on this, I'm kind of shaking because
I was so upset when I found out this morning.
Speaker 1: It's a disgusting thing to be doing.
So let's let's talk about a few things. First
of all, is requiring vaccination a waste of time
if you can fake a vaccine card? No, no system
is foolproof. No system is foolproof. But
it's so easy to get vaccinated. I know you'll
say a lot of people don't want to get vaccinated
for political reasons, and I get that. But it's
so easy to get vaccinated. It's really easy for
most people. It's easier to get vaccinated than to
figure out how to put together a vaccine card that
you feel really would pass muster that. The whole
point is let's just use that to convince more
people to go and get vaccinated. No system is
foolproof. I mean, I'll be honest to get back
to the United States from Europe. I needed a
negative test within 72 hours of coming back.
And I did one. I got one. I brought a test with
me that I connect with someone. It's called a
telehealth observation. They watch me do the
test. I put the drops in the thing. They verify
that I did it correctly. It comes back negative.
They send me a PDF. I could have picked the PDF.
I mean, you know, at Frankfurt Airport, it was
five seconds that they looked at it and really
all they looked at was, does it say negative? Does
it say my name? And is the date within three days,
I could have been showing anything at all. Are
some people probably faking the negative test?
Yes, but for enough people, it's difficult
enough to know how do I make a, you know,
a good looking PDF this that I'll just go and get
myself to test? Any system is going to have some
people that get around it. No system is foolproof.
I don't think that's a reason not to do it now.
What essentially is being done when you fake a CDC
vaccination record is you are using an official
government agency, SEAL. Without authorization,
and that's a crime. OK, so when people do that,
there may be law written to specifically go for
faking vaccination, but faking a CDC certificate
is a crime. It can be punishable under Title 18,
U.S. Code, Section 10, 17 and other laws. So it is
a crime. So you should report it. If, you know,
if people that are doing this, this is really
it's an attack on humanity, really, because what
you're doing is you're endangering people. And
the recommendation is you call one 800 HHS tips
or you can go to ISEE three dot gov. That's for
Internet crime. I don't know if it's exactly an
Internet crime, but that's another recommendation.
So one 800 HHS tips or I see three dot gov. You
can also contact local law enforcement. You can
contact your local district attorney, attorney.
Almost anyone should be able to direct you as to
what to do. So not only should we make it easier
to just get vaccinated than to fake a certificate,
we should really be making examples out of
people that are caught faking the certificates.
I've already read, in fact, that because the
card can be faked that there's going to be a
different method and electronic record may be or
whatever the case may be, we're going to have to
wait and see. All right. It's so great to
be back. We have a fantastic bonus. Show
producer Pat will defiantly and heroically rejoin
me on the award winning world famous bonus show.
I am going to talk to you about my trip. I'm going
to talk to you about positive covid test. I have a
story from my trip that I'm calling positive covid
test. And we will talk about so many other things
that are taking taking place and things we
missed during my break and so on and so forth. So
get instant access. You go to join Patman dot com,
you sign up. We did do a 16th anniversary special.
If you missed the email and you want the code,
send an email to info at David Pakman dot com. You
are not going to want to miss. I'll give you.
I don't have covid ok. I don't have code,
but I'm going to give you a story that
is crazy involving a positive covid test
over my trip. So sign up it. Join Pakman dot com
will speak to you then. We're here tomorrow. I
look forward to taking some of your calls on
the Friday show. It's really great to be back.